hey what's up my name's samuel lee and
in this video i wanted to respond to
robert
lundy robert lundy if you're watching
this firstly robert
robert if that is your real name
thank you for asking a question on my
youtube channel you know what robert i'm
going to answer your question also
darren mcgarry i'm going to answer your
question superstar izzy may alex
schofield billy stevenson username
cannot be blank razvan gabriel liam
outdoor timmins mma man i'm going to
answer your questions right now so thank
you for subscribing thank you for asking
questions if you're a subscriber of mine
you know what
comment a question below in the comment
box and you know what next week i'll
answer your question too so firstly
robert londo
this is what robert said hey if you're
not subscribed do me a massive favor
subscribe right now also i have to say
this is so important
by hitting the like button
you don't lose anything it doesn't cost
any money you are not leaving a part of
you somewhere else it doesn't cost any
money um so please do me a massive favor
and just hit like like but hit like that
would mean so much to me and then uh ask
me a question below and i'll be
answering your questions around property
investment as best i can robert
i'm an i'm an aspiring deal saucer and
i've booked onto your deal selling
masterclass boom well done brother
one question i have is i've found it
tricky booking viewings as i've had
multiple agents ask for a mortgage in
principle before they can book a viewing
is there anywhere around this all right
robert lundy first thing i'm going to
say is this
when you ring up to book a viewing they
will always ask you are you buying
mortgage or cash they'll always ask you
are you going to be
what's the purpose of the purchase and
what they mean by that is residential
namely are you going to live in it or
investment
they'll always ask you for your address
your email so they can just fill out a
form and put you on the system so when
they ask you those questions rather than
thinking like oh my gosh um freaking out
just just answer them just say it's
going to be investment purposes
if they ask about how you're going to be
financing it
you could say cash or mortgage whatever
the answer is if you're going to be
buying this property on behalf of
somebody else then answer it on behalf
of them so just say my name is robert
lundy yeah i'll be purchasing it
with a mortgage it's all in place it's
all sorted because
you might not be buying it but the
person that you're looking for is also
if the if you've got investors that
you're trying to source for
you can use the investors
proof of funds and and mortgage in
principle to show the estate agent
estate agents right now in 2021
that it's definitely a popping market
right now so there's a lot of people
wanting to buy properties and they might
try and sometimes weed out the serious
and the non-serious by asking some
questions up front but just be honest
and tell them tell them whether it's
cash or mortgage tell them um your
situation they don't like deal sources
because deal sources are mostly time
wasters and window shoppers that find a
property and then can't even sell it or
aren't actually working with any serious
investors of course for you robert londy
that's not going to be the case because
you're working with me on the training
soon so i hope that helps if it doesn't
help ask another question or ask me a
slightly different way and i look
forward to working with you real soon
okay darren mcgarry what's up brother he
says how much money would you recommend
needing to have to start off in buy
refurbished refinance what credit score
is realistically needed
depends you don't need any money and you
don't need any good credit either do you
know why because when i started in buy
refurbished finance
i bought my first house for a hundred
thousand
refinanced it for 120 i was 17. i had no
money
i had no ability to get credit what did
i do borrowed people's money borrowed
people's credibility so you can always
leverage not only can you leverage other
people's money but you can leave which
other people's time other people's
skills other people's credit so it's
just about bringing people together in
on your vision so um i mean you say
realistically i mean what
if you're doing it yourself
realistically doing it yourself without
bringing people in i'd say you probably
need about 30 40 000
um to start with biorefurbishing finance
and then the rest you can just get a
bridging loan credit wise you just need
to speak to a mortgage broker that says
that your credit is
um
reasonable just yes you qualify for a
mortgage and that's that superstar i
have another question can you possibly
pay your previous mortgage by using your
refinanced property i'm grateful for
your videos and wishes you the best
superstar thank you so much i appreciate
you your superstar um yeah you can you
can refinance
a property
and then
sorry pay your previous mortgage by
using yeah you can shuffle around so if
you've got a property that you can pull
equity out of you can then put that
towards another property i mean as long
when you're getting a mortgage it's all
it's just about being honest with the
lender about what you're doing so
generally speaking that's what i do all
the time i'll refinance here and i'll
pay here and i'll shuffle money around
and get the best rates so yeah you can
do that okay izzy ma says is rent to
rent
still a practical strategy especially up
north where almost every agent doesn't
seem to understand it and landlords say
no i would say izzy may if landlord if
agents don't understand it
that's a good thing
i love it when i go into an estate
agency and i say hey i'm looking to do
a company let where i can take on the
the property and i'll be putting my
clients into the property this is how it
works and if they're like what i love it
because if they've never heard of it
before if the agents haven't heard of it
in a particular part of the country then
that's like
ripe
that means that
the agent isn't getting pitched every
day by people looking to do rent to
rents that's a good thing
so you're saying
is renter and still practical especially
up north where almost every agent
doesn't seem to understand it your job
is to educate them and landlords saying
no if i ask you
how many landlords have you spoken to
that have said no guaranteed there's not
more than six or seven
yet i could find
in five minutes
70 landlords in your area
so
got to speak to more people
speak to more people and improve what
you're saying improve your skill if
you're constantly thinking i need to
improve my skill i need to improve my
sales pitch and i need to pitch to more
people i need to see more people see
more people see more people get better
get better get better and you're doing
these two things together that's when
you're going to get rich
so yes it's very viable up north 100
man i've got so many students killing it
up north manchester newcastle leeds
bradford huddersfield killing it at rent
and rents all right alex schofield
what do you recommend people do to get a
property to an epc banned c ready for
2025 government legislation on rentals
this will be costly
good question
it's about being aware of it it won't
necessarily be costly either
in fact often you're talking a few
thousand pounds it depends on the
property also i'd be using it as a
negotiation technique to buy cheap so if
there's a property that's an ebc band d
or an e i'd be like hang on
yes that's legal now but soon i'm gonna
have to spend money on on on you know
maybe adding some insulation or whatever
it might be to get the epc down
so that's going to have to reflect on
the price so here's my offer
so i just it's just about being aware of
it and if anyone doesn't know what we're
talking about ebc stands for energy
performance certificate and a is really
good
uh an e is
not great anything higher than an e
means the property is not energy
efficient and it means that you can't
legally rent the property out in 2025
they're gonna they're saying that it has
to be c top end
you can see on the energy performance
certificate you can see what the
potential of the property has so if it
says oh it's currently a d but it has
potential to be a b
you can see that oh okay
so it has the potential
it just needs a little bit of money what
needs to be spent what needs to happen
it's simple i wouldn't worry about it
too much i'll just be aware of it
by the way if you're enjoying this hit
the like don't cost you anything to hit
the like button drop a question as well
and i'll do my best to answer billy
stevenson how much are sourcing fees
roughly for each type of deal
generally speaking for like a basic
vanilla buy to let
that's just like oh it stacks up
so by to let you might be talking about
one and a half thousand pounds
for maybe
a hmo property with a really good return
you might be talking two or three
thousand
for a buy refurbished refinance where
you're going to be able to buy it at
value pull your money out
you're probably talking three to four
grand if it's a really juicy brr pull
all your money out and hma you might be
talking five grand
um
standard of course it depends on
the the the buyer and depends on the
value of the house like if you're
talking you know you're probably gonna
struggle to get a five thousand pound
finders fee
on a property that's a hundred grand
house
because that's a five percent
finders fee
you might get a ten grand finders fee
for a house in london that's just a
vanilla buy to let because you've
negotiated to buy it for 1 million
pounds
the value is 1.1 million you've got a
little bit of a deal on it
you've got a tenant lined up and someone
might say well i want to buy in london
you've just negotiated a hundred grand
off the price sure man i'll give you 10
grand
so it's all relative
ultimately with every deal if you're a
deal sorcerer it's about having a
willing buyer and a willing seller like
all business what are they prepared to
pay does it work for you does it work
for the investor uh if so boom shaka
let's get that money in the bank
all right username cannot be blank i
guess it's not blank technically so
we're all good we're in the safe zone i
have a very varied share portfolio circa
500 000 pounds and i'm achieving 15 to
20 gain per annum
do you think it would be best to invest
some of this in property if so how
listen
i'm not a financial advisor okay and and
i not only am i not a financial advisor
but also i can't stand here and say what
you should and should not do with your
money i don't know loads about um
investing in shares either 15 to 20 gain
per annum i assume you're talking
capital gain i don't know if you're
getting any cash flow each month
i like cash flow i like to buy the
reason i like property so much is
because i buy it and it goes up in value
over time and i'm getting monthly cash
flow i think property is one of the best
investments there is so of course i
would say profit i would put some of it
into property you got half a million
damn you could do some damage
just
even if you just say look i'm not i'm
not too familiar with property i'm gonna
just sort of start with a little um a
little house flip a fixer-upper or
something
personally
if i'm really honest i'd say that
property is not a is not the best
investment on the planet the best
investment is you if you've got half a
million and you're looking to grow that
as best you can i'd probably put just i
don't know one percent of that money
into yourself into your own education
and learn about the best ways to invest
in property the best areas and you know
and and
grow yourself and grow your knowledge
and then probably that you'll find that
that's the best investment um but
definitely would look at property and
i'm happy to help out you know come and
join me at one of the events and we can
chat i'll leave a link in the
description come down let's meet let's
talk and um
yeah i hope to see you get richer and
richer so awesome all right razvan
gabriel is there any way to legally have
more than two lodges thanks
all right testing my knowledge now right
okay two lodges um okay
if you are living
in the house you're a living landlord
you can have two lodges
no problem and you also aren't gonna pay
tax you're gonna get bedroom relief tax
on the first seven and a half thousand
pounds
you won't pay any tax
if there's more than two lodges then the
property even if you're living there
will become a hmo
so of course you can put you can if
you've got like four rooms rent them out
but
your property will become a hmo if it's
more than two lodges so it does change
things slightly um if you're not living
in the property if it's just a property
you're not there then one lodger is okay
but more than one lodger
it becomes a hmo so
that's my understanding and i'm not
quite sure what your situation is
so happy to help further but um i mean
to be honest you could probably speak to
the council on this stuff and they'll
give you the information as well but
that's best of my knowledge
that is that is um
legally what the situation is with
lodges if it helps
liam outdoor timmins is the current
market cell or brr system
depends
i think
brr
buying a house adding value and then
refinancing
works
with a great market for brr the question
is if you buy a house and you refurb it
do you want to refinance it or do you
want to sell it
and the answer is it depends on this
you want to work your numbers backwards
you want to look at if you refinance it
you need to say what is the situation
then okay let me give you an example if
you buy a house for 100 grand
and then you're going to spend 50 on it
and then you know the end value is 200
000.
great
but the end values if you refine that
set you're going to have a mortgage of
150.
so you need to work backwards and say
well hold on if i've got a new mortgage
of 150 what are my mortgage payments
going to be
work it out
and what's the rent going to be on that
house
work it out
and then am i going to be in profit
every month
you need to be cash flowing a minimum of
200 pounds per month positive
for it to stack
so
if the situation is if i refinance it my
mortgage payments are going to be this
and my rent's going to be this and i'll
be making nothing then you may as well
sell it and just take the
50 grand
cash and
do it as a flip
the disadvantage of a flip is unless you
live in the house
if you buy a house fix it up sell it
you're gonna have to pay capital gains
tax which is about 28
unless you do it through a company you
could then you could then get away with
corporation tax
if you refinance it you're gonna pay no
tax you're going to keep the house but
it's all about knowing well what then
what's the end game is that property you
don't want properties in your portfolio
unless they're cash flowing positive so
i hope that helps you might want to
watch that back you have to watch that a
couple times for that to understand that
but you understand these formulas if you
start learning this
because it's simple investing in
property is simple if you know how and
anyone can do it so liam hope that helps
all right mma man last question we got
if you've got a question for me if i'm
not answered it ask again go ahead
comment your questions mma man says
i know some people who buy land
apply for finance to build house
then we mortgage house
they're able to pay
the finance company back and receive
their initial investment money for the
land and they also have a house to rent
out have you heard of this and what are
your thoughts i've done this yes i think
again
i mean look i build houses as part of my
strategy it's development and if you
have the same thing as the last question
that makes sense i mean when we built
some houses in lincoln the houses were
quite cheap houses there were about 220
grand so
we could
we had both options we if we refinance
the house we can still make money or we
can sell the house both options work so
yeah that's a good strategy it makes
sense as long as the
numbers stack as long as you're making
25 profit net profit on your deal um
then it works i hope you found this
video helpful i'm doing videos like this
every day answering your questions in
property so that you don't have to make
the same mistakes i made if you enjoy my
videos subscribe ask questions hit the
like button and i'll see you guys next
time peace
[Music]